all right dr. Anthony foul she says more
than one coronavirus vaccine will likely
be needed to end the pandemic because of
overwhelming demand in an unprecedented
race more than 100 potential vaccines
are being tested at record speeds drug
maker Moderne got FDA approval last week
to start a second round of clinical
trials and Pfizer began human trials of
its vaccine candidate in the u.s. chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook
looks at the science behind those fast
tracking efforts this novel coronavirus
comes and you say no problem we can make
that vaccine really quickly we got this
that's what I said kiss me Kia Corbett
leads the National Institutes of Health
vaccine collaboration with moderna
at the start of the outbreak in January
she told us the stars vaccine gave
researchers a huge head start it would
take just two months to bring their
kovin 19 vaccine to human trials we
actually changed the genetic code for
the spike protein based on our knowledge
that we gathered from designing vaccines
for other coronaviruses in the past that
spike protein is the key the corona
virus uses to unlock and invade a body
cells modernness vaccine uses genetic
material known as messenger RNA to
instruct cells to make spike proteins
that trigger an immune response to fight
the virus what did they tell you with
the potential risks really really sick
as one of the first American volunteers
from wilderness trial 61 year old Carol
Kelly received her first dose in late
April tell me why you wanted to do this
there are so many people that are
suffering and I thought here is an
opportunity that just presented itself
and I need to do what I can at Johnson &
Johnson researchers are using a
different approach they take a piece of
coronavirus DNA and place it inside a
weakened cold virus triggering an immune
response we have used it so many times
before that we know what we have to do
in order to get very quickly to a
vaccine Johnson & Johnson
chief scientific officer dr. Paul
Stoffels says the company can have a
billion doses ready by next year what
would you say to people who are thinking
you know this is going so fast I'm
worried about the safety it's a
biological vector which has been used a
lot in animals and in people from small
kids to elderly from people who are
healthy to people who are very sick like
an HIV so we have been testing that in a
very controlled way already accelerating
the vaccine timeline has raised some
questions about safety
Harvard immunologist dr. Barry bloom
says compressing the process does not
mean safety measures are being cut we're
turning up the flame on the whole
development and rolling out process and
you don't think it's doing it at the
risk of increased side effects or
sacrificing safety I don't think anybody
is thinking about compromising in any
manner shape or form but we will only
know that after the initial safety
studies when there's nothing obviously
but even if we see a successful vaccine
by early next year bloom says it will
likely take several years before enough
people are immunized to create
widespread protection and a realistic
expectation would be it's going to make
a difference in two to three makes
difference in two to three years a real
difference and not just in the US but
hopefully in many other countries and
dr. Jon LaPook joins us now John good
morning in this on this question of
safety which you raised in this
accelerated development process are
there any steps that are being either
skipped or compressed
compressed is is probably the better
term Anthony and his Makia Corbett told
me how impressive is she that that first
step which took 20 months for SARS and
about two months right now for the Cova
19 what they basically did was they took
the SARS vaccine they unscrewed the part
that specific for SARS and they screwed
on the part that's specific for kovin 19
something akin to that which is amazing
in terms of compressing that first stage
and four stages two and three where
you're testing safety and also whether
it lists an immune response they're
combining them rather
doing Phase two stopping analyzing the
data starting on Phase three they're
putting them together and they're only
gonna stop if there's some kind of a
safety problem all right John thank you
very much dr. Jon LaPook